she sent a box of tissues yes i do
northwest is at it again trolling her
mom kim kardashian
it's her life on tuesday kim showed off
a care package she received from olivia
rodrigo
in celebration of the singer's first
studio album sour
check it out the reality star received
all kinds of goodies
like bumper stickers notebooks tissues
and even sour patch kids
how cute is olivia rodrigo you guys
i can't wait for her album you guys know
i love driver's license
[Music]
but north begs to differ clapping back
to her mom that she's never heard her
listen to the chart-topping hit
you guys know i love driver's license
like she sent a box of tissues
yes i do i listen to it all the time
then kim says she's excited for olivia's
album
i can't wait for her album but kim the
album is actually already out
it dropped may 21st
leave it to her five-year-old son saint
to set the record straight
stop north saint don't we listen to
everyone in the car all the time yes
can you say that louder for the people
to hear do i listen to it all the time
saint
yeah see you guys
what a cutie but this isn't the first
time north has shaded her famous mom
back in october kim showed off these
stunning floral arrangements she
received on her 40th birthday
and north's reaction was priceless they
are
so i love this color i'm dying
these are so no you're not or you're
being the great
and it looks like the apple doesn't fall
far from the tree in february kim
sarcastically trolled her mom kris
jenner
for rocking this bold ensemble who makes
your outfit
i can't figure it out got two guesses
no it's never a dull moment i'm so
curious
as to really who makes this truly we
love the kardashian jenners because they
have no problem being trolled by each
other
and seemingly anyone in their outside
circle
especially natalie franklin the creator
and writer behind the viral parody
instagram account
nori's blackbook who remained anonymous
for eight years until she revealed her
identity on keeping up with the
kardashians earlier this month
black box and merlin noel for dashing
once
e.t spoke with natalie shortly after her
keeping up debut
you're all about comedy and laughs but
of course you know you're talking about
real people on this account
and i could very easily see this could
be a situation where
things might get litigious or some cease
and desist letters
um has that ever been a concern of yours
have you actually ever
received any um letters on behalf of the
family saying
you gotta you know tweak this or take it
down or we don't like the account
if i got a cease and desist and desist
letter from the kardashians i'd frame it
like what an honor like what an honor
that would be i wish i don't think i'm
important enough to get a decent
distance
like i'm not making that impact enough
but i would have loved that but no they
the family from what i the few
interactions i have they're actually
really good sports they
have this great ability to laugh at
themselves they don't take themselves
too seriously